so we have Ryan Williams who's gonna
tell us about the complexity of solving
systems of phenomena equations thanks
for the introduction
thanks for coming so by invoking this
fine-grain adjective I'm going to allow
for algorithms which slightly beat
exhaustive search for solving systems
and I'm gonna talk about conjectures and
hardness results for a slightly beating
exhaustive search so the reason I wanted
to speak about this is it has some
proofs and ideas which I think would be
of interest to this audience so let's
start with the problem so in this top
we'll be looking at Meili prime fields
so F F P where P is prime and K be some
positive integer look at degree K F P
system solvability where you're given a
set of M polynomials and n variables
whose degrees are at most K and we want
to know if there if there's a solution
to them so if there is some assignment
to the variables which say makes all the
polynomials vanish it's a 0 set empty or
not ok so in this talk we'll think of P
and K as small like constants and n is
quite large and P is say smaller than
then ok ok or I say we're smaller than
like exponential in K so this particular
setting of parameters is of interest for
various crypto systems like for example
like quadratic systems of equations
where you're like the crypto system is
based on the hardness of solving a
quadratic system so just to get used
this notation so if I have degree ones
linear equations and then I can solve
this problem in P by a Gaussian
elimination if I only have one equation
then I'm just trying to find a root of
one degree K polynomial which would say
and I'm giving you the list of
coefficients the monomials explicitly in
this finding roots so this this you can
solve them in polynomial time
but if I allow you arbitrarily many
equations in I look at F 2 degree 2 it's
already empty heart so the easiest way
to see is a reduction from not all equal
3sat so I'll do want to say that they're
quite a few algorithms known when n is
small so for example
Niraj gave the talk at Simons several
years ago in our of neutrons in time
which is polynomial for a fixed fixed in
but it's a degree to the some
exponential in term time but for our
case where we're looking at just some
finite feel like F P we have n variables
we want to know if we can be P to the N
just you know the brute force algorithm
was trying all the possible assignments
and so something that was that was
started in the fine-grained semester at
Simon's and 2015 eventually worked out
with look shot off pottery Tamaki
watching you and myself is that yes you
can beat exhaustive search this
particular running time so so it's P to
the N divided by P to the N divided by
order K some some factor in terms of K
it gets worse as K grows the improvement
of exhaustive search and if this is true
for like you know P which is not too
large as a function of K whenever P is
greater you still get some improvement
over exhaustive search though it's it's
slightly worse okay so the first thing I
want to do is tell you about this
algorithm okay so there's a the problem
again in the statement so I was trying
to think of how to explain this
algorithm in some clear and succinct way
and eventually I just decided I would
constrain myself to one slide but I mean
I guess this like yeah there's a very
you know interesting use of white space
I guess you could say you know see
literally
fine fine grain exposition right well
this is actually gonna be coarse green
less that was my that was actually my my
point was that it was getting too
technical so I wanted to be coarse grain
okay yeah so the general idea behind
this algorithm and what makes it
different I think from lots of other
types of algorithms for this problem is
to approach this in a circuit complexity
way okay so try to define a kind of
circuit it's this is some hybrid between
a boolean circuit and a circuit that
takes values from FP as input and then
try to massage this circuit and do some
interesting evaluation on this circuit
so that's the general idea
okay so we're given a set of polynomials
so these are again degree K polynomials
and I partition mentally the set of
variables into they Delta n variables
and n minus Delta n variables for some
parameter delta okay and so I'm gonna
define a n minus Delta in input circuit
so that's going to be on the X variables
okay and the idea so this circuit is
doing what it's taking an ore over all
possible assignments to the Y variables
okay so all possible Delta n vectors
it's sticking that assignment in for the
Y variables it's checking whether for
all equations that equation is zero so
this is just this bracket just the
indicator which outputs 1 or 0 depending
whether the predicate inside is true ok
so it's just brute forcing but over
Peter the Delta in partial assignments
ok alright so this is a circuit that
takes in P values but outputs the true
false value but we can think of that as
a as a zero one guy so all right
and so the observation is well
satisfiability for the circuit what does
that correspond to so it's corresponds
to finding a setting to the rest of the
variables so some B vector and then
minus salt integrals that makes this
thing correct one and that's going to
exist if and only if there is a solution
to the whole system this sort of
obviously I mean it's brute-forcing over
a delta and the variables so if I
managed to find something which makes
these things true on the rest of the
variables and there's a there is a
solution to the whole set all right all
right so now I want to sort of solve the
the sap problem for this kind of circuit
that's the idea okay well right where it
takes in value some FP and outputs the
true-false value and want to solve the
satisfiability problem so so adapting
this so well known in complexity work of
reservoir often Smolinski there is a way
to randomly reduce such a circuit so
even this sort of hybrid boolean and FP
circuit to a polynomial of degree which
is not too large so here it's P times
Delta times n times K but it's a single
polynomial okay so that for any
particular input I might give this
circuit this polynomial will output the
correct value in some sense with high
probability so what do I mean by that I
mean that whenever I stick in a B so
this is a worst-case type thing so for
all B when I stick in a B it's going to
be 1 so if it's 1 then the choice over
the randomness of this q sub s B will be
non zero with probability greater than
2/3 ok so this thing will be nonzero
probability greater than 2/3 this
randomness again is over the choice of
of the Q sub s not over the particulars
assignment and when it's 0 the probably
this is 0 this should be sorry this
should be greater than 2/3 as well ok so
the point is that like the non zero Ness
is telling us whether it's is true or
false with some decent probability and
at a high level the way this kind of
thing works is it's just the look at
anybody who's familiar with Roseboro
Smolinski construction could work this
out very easy to exercise the idea is
you what they show is for an or and for
an end you can represent them
probabilistic with publicity
polynomials of low degree okay there's
some trade-off between the degree that
you'd like to have and the error of the
polynomial sort of like the probability
of error and so the idea is you you just
form appropriate public polynomials for
the ant and for the or here you only
really need constant degree to achieve
this kind of error here you would want
larger degree so degree so you can Union
bound over all these things so like
Delta Delta n K roughly degree so just
replacing these two things are Policy
polynomials you can you can get this
result it's no over all the different
terms in here so like you want to say I
have a probabilistic polynomial which
has this property it's a worst-case
randomized algorithm so it's like in the
worst case no matter what input I've got
the probability gives me the right
answer over the choices of internal
random list the probablistic polynomial
is high yes yes yes so yeah this all I
was saying is you would want the degree
of your politic pond will be say
constant for the or and something like
Delta n for this one so you can account
for all the different possible errors
you might get because there's like Peter
the Delta and different things you have
to account for there that's all
that's why there's a penis and I'm
telling you yeah the random sub sub
trick is a different thing yes but yeah
yeah yeah I do think that the first
person to observe the generalization to
mod B was smoking okay so here's the
algorithm so we set our parameter Delta
to be let's say 1 over 100 cake okay
we're going to end up getting you know
some algorithm like this so that hundred
will end up going there so the idea is
given our set of polynomials we repeat
the following for some constant times n
times so we want to do something so that
it will hold for all the beats so we
have some high probability statement for
all the B's we construct this random q
sub s from s so we we draw a random Q
sub s independently for each trial and
then we evaluate that akyuu sub s on all
possible points B okay so all possible P
to the N minus Delta endpoints all right
so we get a value each time so we we do
this some constant times in time we gets
table P to the N minus Delta in each
time and then we return this a solution
if there exists some sort of column in
this table so it was always nonzero
safer so greater than half the times
because here right we have probably 2/3
of giving you the right answer so we're
just looking at it is if it's nonzero
for a greater than half the time so this
is a two-sided I remember of course we
could make it
one-sided by by using search decision
and forcing it to print something and
then checking that it works okay so
that's that's a the algorithm and so
well for one why does it work in the
desired time so the the first part is
that this part one doesn't take too long
when P is small enough ok because of the
way I set Delta and because of sort of
like the number of possible monomials Q
sub s could have its degree will be
smallish and so this this step is
actually not too arduous it will
actually be a low order term now too
this is going to more or less govern the
running time here because we're looking
at P to the M minus Delta in time
roughly so the point is here given the
polynomial represented as a list of
coefficients you can just evaluate it on
all if the points in FP of the n minus
Delta n in essentially polynomial
amortized time by a divine conquer
approach no matrix multi-run x' in the
desired time and the reason why it works
it's just a simple Chernoff bound Union
bound type argument applied to this
observation here okay it's going to give
me the this is going to give me the
correct answer about all the possible
beasts
so even locates like say a prefix of the
other solution so this is a randomized
algorithm and you can de randomized it
with some with some loss here is some
you'll have some order K so order K term
it depends on P a little bit just a
really high level you can use epsilon
bias generators say for FP to choose
these polynomials and
you can use mana amplifying panels to
compose the these layers of polynomials
over over the integers that's just a
really high-level idea of how the
dynamize just turned out to be
convenient in fact it allows us to count
the number of solutions yeah yeah yeah I
don't know if I have like a good
succinct explanation for it I mean there
are some limits on my ability to be
succinct in one Snyder's yeah yeah the
trade-offs yeah like by saying this
whatever 1 over 100 thing this degree
will actually turn out to be like sort
of way smaller than like the thing but
yeah that's ideas you want to balance
like how many terms you get versus like
the revaluation time that's that's
ideally what you would like to be i t I
[Music]
mean we have some probability of error
so I think could be many points in which
it gives the wrong answer we're not
talking about it being identically 0 on
all points
it's like point 4.0 point 4 point it
gives us the right answer with some
decent probability yeah that would be
way nicer I mean some reduction to piti
maybe harder to do granted - I guess
though yeah yeah ok
all right so that's what's our it's a
really different approach to this kind
of thing so now I want to talk about a
slightly more general problem counting
the solutions so counting the
cardinality of the 0 set so we'll call
this a sharp D KSP okay it's a same as
before except I want to compute the
cardinality of the of the solutions to
the system ok and
computing the rank of the matrix I can
also do this with four linear equations
very interesting not well-known the
result is that if you have one degree
two polynomial over FP you can actually
count the number of solutions in
polynomial time and this goes all the
way back as far as I could trace back
with karlitz in the 60s but even before
that like Dixon sorry yes I think so I
think so yeah you can put them in
canonical for myself yeah I mean that
that works for ya for odd P that makes
it easy for even P you got like so like
for power yeah for like characteristic -
it's it's more calm again this I guess
why I put karlitz they actually work
here just so you can generalize the
algorithm on the previous slide to get a
similar type of thing for counting and
this problem becomes sharpie hard very
quickly so already for degree 2 and F 2
again by natural kind of reduction and
already for a degree 3 and over F 2 it's
still a sharp P hard even when you've
got only one degree three polynomial and
you want to count it's its roots but the
reduction blows up the number of
variables so this is due to Aaron
Florian a corpus key it blows it up by
quite amount so like maybe in in cubed
or something and so the natural kind of
fine-grain question is well how hard is
it
so exponentially hard to count the zeros
of a constant degree f2 polynomial might
we expect like a say at one point 9 9 to
the N time algorithm for this reduction
is blowing up by like in Amanda and cube
then there's no impediment necessarily
there
so recall finding a zero of one
polynomial is relatively easy this we
can do so it's really a problem of
counting versus finding so how hard like
so finding is polynomial time is it
exponentially hard to count or not
that's that's the question we're asking
so so building on some work that I had
earlier this year so this is a theorem
with pretty more Chapman you can prove a
rather strong hardness results so for
all epsilon it's a greater than 0 and C
say greater than 1 we're going to look
at having systems of see in polynomials
on n variables we're gonna have a
deterministic so exponential time
reduction Sophie to the epsilon and time
reduction from the counting problem on
CN polynomials to counting the zeros of
one polynomial okay whose degree has
increased slightly this is interesting
so the thing I want to is that the
reason why I kept talking about the P
the pack therapy because it's important
the factor of P is actually not here so
that this is a that is actually fairly
non-trivial thing so so we can go from a
whole system of linear emini poems to
one polynomial of slightly larger degree
okay so so the idea is that this is
counting solutions to the system of
degree K it's fine-grain equivalent
because we didn't change the variables
at all in fact the number of barrels did
not change we just encourage this act so
exponential type running time the kind
of solutions to one polynomial okay now
okay it's important to say here you know
for completeness if we were working over
the reals this would be really really
easy okay if we were working over the
reals we could just take a sum of the
squares of all the polynomials and then
see it as zero anyway right there's just
only increases the degree by a factor
two no big deal
what's interesting is that this isn't
working over finite fields yeah that's
the interesting part
yeah and it's it's not like just sort of
doing some from a little theorem trick
where I'm raising something the people
it's 1 or whatever and because I there's
no dependence on on the the field size
it means that that they're equivalent
each on a very strong sense that like
the the parameter in so if you had
something to just barely beat exhaustive
search for one equation would already
work for a whole system because the
number of variables did not increase at
all so you know I'm not gonna give a
formal definition of it now but you can
think of it as yours your another
approach to refuting the strong
exponential time hypothesis so so the
idea is that like so so so the idea is
that like there you know the case that
problem is is believed to require say
essentially to the end time you cannot
improve on the base of the exponent
ok even by any particular constant this
is a hypothesis of strongest economic
losses so as K increases it gets harder
and harder and you just like you like
you for any string of mind you can't
solve it faster this is saying that
actually and even even to solve sharp
key set faster it would suffice to count
the zeros of a constant degree so this
constant depending on K polynomial in n
variables over f2 in say 1.99 at n time
ok so I'm like just changing the the
number of nines here for that but the
point if the number of variables didn't
change at all
so having even like a slightly better
than brute force algorithm here gives
you one in the original for the original
problem but that's that's all that's all
yes
some types of previous societies like
for every fix care you can improve a
little bit on the exponent yeah yeah you
can even think of this algorithm for
solving system is a generalization of
case algorithms yeah yeah yeah yeah good
point
yeah thanks yeah all right so this is a
sort of very strong harness result okay
so let me say how this thing works so
first we're going to make a totally do B
assumption no justification for at the
moment we're going to assume the number
of pounds in our system is actually
small so epsilon in where epsilon with
something we chose because everyone
assumed there's not that many
polynomials okay and then we're gonna
remove it okay so so given number
Apollo's is not too many here's our
reduction okay so I'm giving you epsilon
and polynomials okay so let F so let's
sorry I let V 1 to V P to the epsilon
and B enumeration of all vectors of
length epsilon in okay I have two
counters initializes 0 I'm I go through
all the possible vectors and this set so
i numerator all i okay i form a linear
combination of the vectors with these
polynomials okay so so i just take all
possible linear combinations of the
system of polynomials i've got right
this is epsilon n the vectors are of
length epsilon n so this is just a inner
product okay so I'm forming this
polynomial obviously it has the same
degree as whatever you know the degrees
of these things were if this is cases
the UDK okay I'm counting a number of
zeros of this polynomial I'm adding that
to some running to Z I count the number
of zeros of 1 minus upon mu and it's um
running to Lin and then finally after
all I set it done I output Z minus n
divided by the total number of vectors
in this case Peter absolutely there's an
exact reduction yes yeah so so obviously
this thing is degree K if all the poems
are UK so in fact there's no change in
degree here okay yep and this is so this
is one Oracle call to count think the
number of variables didn't change okay
so we're good
and there's another Oracle call to
County this is where we work out so
we're making P to the epsilon n times to
Oracle calls
so why does this thing work so let a be
the set of solutions the system so those
assignments making all the polynomials
vanish okay so so take any solution of
this so anything that makes all the
panels vanish makes this capital P sub I
vanish okay and it does not make one
minus the pond will vanish okay it makes
that bottom of one that's true for all
the vectors okay so that means that
every solution here gets summed up P to
the epsilon n times in this thing and
divided by P to the epsilon so every
solution contributes one to this running
sum okay and similarly everything that's
not a solution makes the the vector of
polynomial is a non zero vector okay and
I'm counting at the number of times that
a that over all possible vectors that a
nonzero vector becomes a zero vector
when I take the inner product okay
that's going to happen exactly one over
P at a time and it comes zero and
exactly one the P at time it comes one
okay so those will cancel out so it's
because I'm counting up the exact same
number there they just completely cancel
and so every non solution contribute
zero all right so under our assumption
this output is the correct count right
of course we've got like epsilon in
there so we would like to have you know
some arbitrary constant tenzin okay so
it's a very very simple reduction okay
so let's let's see how to reduce reduce
to the case of epsilon and Palamas so we
are going to start with CN polynomials
if we want to end up with epsilon in
polynomials so the number of solutions
to the original system equals the lower
solutions to the new system okay so our
first try is to partition the set of
Parnell's into epsilon n groups
so each group has say order C over
epsilon polynomials so just group them
up naturally and form a single
polynomial which is supposed to vanish
if and only if all the ponens vanish
this is the first try alright so yes
this is so people who work over prime
fields this is a very common expression
that you see this is for mods little
theorem being applied here to make sure
is always zero or one and it's a very
standard kind of trick actually so but
this this actually gives us degree P
okay so that's not going to give us what
we want in the end
it's gonna give us so I promise you see
K over epsilon there's an extra factor
of P because this P minus one there okay
even for constant P this was always
interesting yeah it was interesting
enough for Sosa yeah yeah yeah yeah so
the point is that like yes this pond
will vanish if and only if all the
panels in a group in that group it
corresponds to vanish okay so any
solution original system is only
solution new system and non solutions
are non solutions maybe I mean I mean
yeah so this is kind of like where if I
took the product of an that would
compute the or but I want to actually
compute the the and kind of over them so
that's a little so so yes this is like
an ant
so this Junction would be easy you take
the product of them yeah it's not
important and that's actually what we
exploit okay so so there's it's like
this is sort of over constrained because
it gives us zero one value determined
uncle Apollo me
okay well we'll see if what I've got is
the determinant I don't think so
yeah I got like a few minutes left so
yeah okay so they improve the reduction
I have something called brain more
slimmer Whitmore's my PCC so so the idea
is you if you give in say to the T
polynomials we can construct of the
greedy thing start to pawn off degree to
the T times D which does the job so
there's no factor of P the way this
works is it uses quadratic residues and
actually non residues modulo P the
determinant okay okay okay so anyway
yeah let me let me skip the beautiful
proof of Brewers theorem so two of them
questions are to obviously to improve
this running time improve it for like
all values of P and n K which we haven't
yet done there's some heuristic
reasonably that actually you could
improve this slightly better and that
would in fact improve the best known
algorithms for key set whatever
super-strong ETH means nobody that's a
little I don't know if nobody believes
it but yeah yeah I don't know if the
strong me neither
yeah I don't know yeah so the question
is could you do it with no blow up in
the degree could you get to a reduction
you don't have to necessarily go through
algebra you could you know do some nice
algorithmic stuff so yeah our right our
algorithm blows up by some factor if the
answer were yes for K equals 2 if we
could preserve degree with selection
time reduction then ETH would be false
so probably not mainly because counting
with one problem it can be done in poly
time so ok that's all thank you
[Applause]
yes to improve case scenario for so I
know that if you can prove the system
you can improve case that but you'd like
to know if you get better sent here
who's so that question it's a natural
one I'm not sure I thought about it so
okay look it's thanks Ryan again
[Applause]